hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
candy's 3 now we're continuing on with
this second night we survived the first
one it was only the rat been in there am
i back here hello
how did it go Oh wonderfully you managed
to beat them awesome job it was it only
the monster rat could be more don't
celebrate yeah those monsters are very
persistent he will probably come back
even stronger don't be scared
remember the static last night then
everything should be fine
you already have your stuff so you want
to you can skip the deep scale and go to
sleep right away still stuff out there
to be discovered if you feel like
playing detective at ease okay I'll go
out I like playing detective my old
dresser I've got nothing else to say
about that it is my dresser and only
that and nothing else okay then I guess
I'm going into the dreamscape hello
beware of the shadows okay I already
knew about that I know I'm good okay
stupid boop boop a bit bit I know where
I am going who will oh do not be afraid
of stepping slightly others the same
messages as before huh so is it like the
dreamscape is the same opening and
reminds you the same things but it's
still slightly different than it once
was continue north to reach the pass oh
okay right
oh hey I didn't make it who did fun he
did okay so maybe if I continue north
from here I'll be okay something did you
guys see that the black shadow okay all
right then
so how haha
north towards the path halfway through
the darkness
turn east oh ah good
incomplete instructions a that's naughty
that's West
ah okay found something even though I
went the wrong way okay
all right then a part of a newspaper
article read it
sure experience a show like never before
with puppeteering technology of the
future the rat and cat will take you on
a new adventures to brand new an
exciting world of fun hey man thank you
release was a go now this time I gotta
turn east but apparently I [ __ ] an
Easter egg that probably very few people
have found just because I can't remember
my goddamn direction dick
oh [ __ ] it go far enough
Oh sad again there anything on the back
of here eat from this rock okay alright
then lady then yeah hi oh I saw it I
always had that it's there it exists
there how do you get there though
OOP you ever do any revenue over there
oh I made it holy [ __ ] I made it okay so
it was possible holy [ __ ] alrighty then
oh where am i this roads all fragmented
yeah oh that's not good
I said good Hey okay alright hey yeah
yeah okay alright then
hello what are you what is this Oh sound
arcade game number two well good for me
what else is here nothing alrighty then
anything else but they found the arcade
game so that's good I think do I have it
still probably huh okay so I found that
so that's good I don't know what that
does for me though you already have your
stuff so you want to you can skip the
deep scape and go to sleep right away
the stuff out there to discover it if
you like playing detective let me go let
me just make sure I got it I'll be right
back real quick yeah I got it I got it
okay I got it I got it so I got that no
need to worry about that so we can just
go right into the actual night but
that's that's interesting alright let's
go to sleep bye bye everybody
second night so hopefully our unhoped
Lee there's more monsters waiting for me
in the darkness so I gotta be even more
intensive than I was last time which
should be fun let's see let's see play
my pee play thirdly to sleep with your
sweet lies ah yes so comforting in here
so does that mean that the cat is going
to be present now because if it is I
don't know if it's going to be any
different but the cat in my dream
suggested that it might actually be the
same but I'll still be ready to punch
him up his rectum
if he even comes remotely close to me if
he is even coming from the normal ways
that the other one came from why I
didn't see nothing there
was it the cat of the rat who's it the
rat in the Hat the cat in the rat were
they doing something the nursery rhyme I
don't want to be part of I'm gonna do it
oh come on now well that hi okay how did
you preach arge my tape here that's how
it works right I'm a millennial I don't
get rewinding yeah anybody write
flip-flopping woo I heard that whoa dad
oh hey all right then [ __ ] okay only
when I venture into the unknown that I
only I'm a little bit apprehensive
what's going on here yeah I'm not
telling my nightmare story I've got a
lot more nightmare stories but by the
way in case you guys actually wanted to
hear all that like when I say I have
nightmares all the time I am not joking
I have nightmares almost every other
night and a lot of the times I'll have
what are called waking nightmares where
you wake up but you don't know you're
awake you're still dreaming so you kind
of hallucinate things in your room and
you hallucinate seeing things like in
the shadows and and you're literally
trapped there you can't move because
your body is still frozen and so your
mind is like halfway between dreaming
and reality and that happens to me
not actually what would that pay okay
all right then gonna rewind gonna be
kind okay so that happens to me a lot
like not as often as the normal
nightmares in general but like that does
happen a lot where I'm I'm just lying in
bed after I have woken up or at least I
think maybe I've woken up at the time it
doesn't feel like it though so usually
what happens is I know there's someone
coming into my room like someone is
trying to get in someone is like taking
steps closer and go that oh that oh that
high [ __ ] high okay oh you were
distracting me is that what you were
doing
ah let's play a game
squeak emic squeak ursin yeah oh hi
how's it going
okay yooba dooba dooba okay gonna play
my tape don't mind me all right so yeah
it's usually like that I'm locked in my
body and I think someone is walking
towards my bed and it may or may not be
with the attention to hurt me or not
but someone in your room that you don't
know is just walking in that's usually
bad so that's usually when I I start to
panic and the worst thing is you can't
move like I can't move when that
happening like I literally am stuck in
bed unable to move it and like I'm
fighting as hard as I can to be able to
move and then suddenly I'll be free and
wake up and it all like violently throw
myself out of bed and just like it's one
of those moments where you wake up
breathing heavy from a nightmare but I
was living the nightmare the whole time
thinking that someone was stalking
towards my bed it's just as bad as it
sounds those ones actually still they
still scare me Oh
okay hey how's it go all right don't you
god I don't even know how to beat you
with this [ __ ] is it even possible I
mean all I'm doing is shining a light in
your eyes kind of already was there
looming over my bad all right for ya
buddy boo hey heard that hello yeah that
happens maybe like once or twice like
once every two months or so is what I'd
say for that one but the normal
nightmares having all the time yeah
there's even like weirder occasions that
happened a long long time ago I remember
this one that stands out in my memory
much like much like the that one time
long ago but this is when I was a
teenager probably around I think I was
like 14 maybe I was I was in bed and I
don't remember having a nightmare that
night but I remember waking up in the
middle of the night I woke up for no
apparent reason and when I looked up at
the ceiling
it was crawling like the ceiling was
moving I have one of those textured
ceilings you know the stucco patterns
whatever it is so I think it was just my
eyes playing tricks on me but for some
reason and I don't really know why I got
out of bed I got out of bed and grabbed
my notebook oh [ __ ] I didn't remind that
oh yeah yeah oh yeah yeah
so I hello who's there hi okay so I
remember I got out of bed and I grabbed
my notebook and a pencil and I went down
stairs and I kind of just it I I really
don't know why but I laid down or I sat
down at the base of the stairs in the
darkness and I just stared at the
doorway next to it the hallway entryway
archway and I just stared there and I
sat there and I couldn't tell if I was
dreaming or not I really couldn't tell
like what I was doing or what was going
on I
just remember our staring at the store
weights watching it morph and shift and
and like change and I would blink and I
would think that something was there
like this this shadow looming in the
hallway like entryway like I don't know
I don't know why I was just sitting
there staring at it and he would go and
he would be there and he would be gone
and then he would come back and it was
just big moving shadow like shifting and
like morphing in the darkness and I knew
I knew at the time it was just my eyes
playing tricks on me and I wasn't really
scared at that point I was kind of
creeped out but I wasn't scared
so hey okay alright this [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you damn it
there's no way to win that I did pretty
good on that one I think [ __ ] out okay
well I don't know what that was all
about I don't know what was with that
noise but it covered up any possibility
of me hearing him creak out I don't look
done almost done there I willed my hand
on my mic stand
ah damn it ah [ __ ] okay alright then
whoa I got him to go away
holy [ __ ] I've never done that before
what the [ __ ] whoo all right fairness I
didn't even know if that was possible
but I must have done good
maybe my reflexes are getting better
with that go hey go back over there okay
so yeah to recap my story I'm at the
bottom of the stairwell staring into the
entryway into the darkness and I see
occasionally like very occasionally this
big moving shadowy figure just it's kind
of like in the static of the darkness
like I just see the outline of it no
details just arms legs body and head and
so I take my notebook and I just start
sketching the doorway like the whole
entryway and I sketch just trying to get
like a picture of what I saw I'm not
100% sure why but I was just sitting at
the bottom of the stairwell in the
darkness it was like 3:00 a.m. sketching
and then I can't even see what I'm
drawing because it's so dark so I just
kind of get a rough outline and then I
look closely at what I was drawing and I
see what I drew it I literally just drew
this shadowy figure standing in the
doorway and for some reason when I did
that it made it really real for me like
maybe I was still dreaming at that point
but I was physically downstairs and so
like I sort of realized where I was and
looked around and I was just like I had
this overwhelming sense of dread like
this isn't a ghost story anything this
isn't anything like that nothing
supernatural happened but this is really
what happened to me and and I had no no
justification for why I was doing that
and why I was down there and why I drew
this shadowy figure in the archway in
the middle of the night like I had
nothing to prove I had nothing to do
there was no reason for me to do it I
wasn't ghost hunting
for some reason went downstairs I just
sat in the darkness drawing the shadow
monster staring back at me oh and that
was the creepiest point I don't even
think I mentioned it I drew eyes like
not real like descriptive eyes I drew I
hold in the thing and I couldn't see
that in the darkness but for some reason
I drew it with eyes I just felt like it
was looking at me and it was horrifying
[ __ ] hello picking up
okay hard please dad okay
oh yeah from that point on like I was I
was like I was shook basically and we
didn't even have that word back then but
I was shook with a capital ship and so
high I I couldn't go back to my bed
because like the ceiling was still
crawling to me the ceiling was still
moving it was like I was out of the
dream finally and yet the dream was
still around me so I uh we had our
golden retriever buddy
they're not chica buddy who's an awesome
dog that you guys are probably seen
videos developing pictures of I I called
the buddy and I just had to go lay on
the couch I couldn't go through that
doorway the the archway but I went
around it and it's just like okay I
things get foggy after that I I think
like I called out to Buddy because I
didn't want to me and yeah oh yeah
that's my other nightmare story I've got
you go there's like that oh boy oh girl
okay all right then
my parents dragged me over here with my
little sister but I'd rather be on my
bike with my friends you're my little
sister by the way [ __ ] you
alright then sure okay wallah why this
place so horrifying eyes everything's
awful in its place stock costumes aren't
even back convincing i watch the rap
from behind it be still to defend
forward and you can see this big metal
zipper lock thing behind his neck I
think it was bear to keep his head from
falling off and such
looks pretty uncomfortable to wear felt
like that totally breaks the atmosphere
alrighty then staff area boys only
sure okay there's a bunch of newspaper
clippings it's a poster for the rat in
the cat theatre they need to advertising
their own theatre do they hello dad is
that you
there's my girl ain't any friends today
no not at all everyone Hey
I don't have to go ask your boys
restroom okay that hasn't changed
I'm just wondering when it's gonna start
murdering everybody quack at all please
don't hog the game share with everyone
oh hi your dress looks almost the same
as mine
we should be friends okay should we I'll
do that okay okay bye then
oh hey hello there I'm the cat do you
like to play games I know I do we have a
couple of minutes before today's John's
argh
hey Lafayette be with me sure hey you
hide and I'll count all righty then
backstage employees only all right hello
hi did you like to show yesterday I kind
of liked it oh boy Katherine get down
from this quick little are gaining good
very surprising nice your scribing yeah
okay all right oh I get it your granddad
you're such a klutz a rough life you
live kid I'm about to be murdered so
should I hide in the exact same table
that I've retired in or maybe I could
hide by the table to my dad that maybe
that'll be good for me hey I could hide
in here hide in the closet tell ya hey
and I sure I got you yeah yeah alright
then that cats good that's real good
okay so anyway that's all the time oh
it's the cat there now that's the cat I
can notice by the cat eyes it's
different so anyway that's the second
episode of five bags of candy Street
it's getting real good I like it a lot I
uh I believe that the cat is gone
answer the next one hopefully that's not
going to kill us at least I know now
that it is technically possible to get
them to go away if they're out field so
either way thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know what you think
down the comments below and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]